Our last example involves
a company called D2Hawkeye,
a medical software
company founded in 2001.
The company combined
data with analytics
to improve quality and cost
management in health care.
In 2009, the company was
analyzing 20 million people
monthly.
It is impossible for humans to
sift through patient records
and assess quality and
cost without algorithms.
This motivated the approach
that D2Hawkeye took.
Let us discuss the data
that D2Hawkeye utilized.
Health care industry
is data rich,
but data may be hard to assess.
It is often unstructured
and unavailable.
The company used insurance
data regarding procedures,
prescriptions, and diagnosis.
It further defined
new risk factors
based on doctor's insights.
For example, obesity
and depression.
Finally, it used
demographic information,
like gender and age.
What were the analytics used?
The goal was to predict
future heath care costs,
and identify high-risk
patients to be
prioritized for intervention.
The company created
interpretable models
for doctors to
analyze and verify.
This led to significant
improvements
over just using
historical costs.
So what is the edge?
The analytics used led to
substantial improvement
in D2Hawkeye's
ability to identify
patients who need
more attention.
The approach allowed
expert knowledge
to identify new variables and
refine existing variables.
Further, it allowed the
ability to make predictions
for millions of patients
without manually
reading patient's files.